[Music]
Jeff Goldblum he's gonna come back in
Jurassic Park could we see you I love
Ellie Sattler I just want to see her
just drag that leg feminist we need we
need her back yes we do
laura dern was playful with et in
december about her possible return to
the blockbuster franchise but her
co-star Jeff Goldblum is confirmed he
told us he'd be thrilled to reunite with
Dern on screen it would be good news to
me unto everyone when Ellie Sattler
returns a very powerful brilliant woman
she is Laura Anna Ellie Sadler we get to
see you are flirting up a storm with her
again because I like that banter from
the first one good when I put water on
her on her hand in order to touch it a
little bit what was it like being back
on that set again for Jurassic quite
quite wonderful Jay a Bayona
director is a very brilliant director I
think it's gonna be something I like
playing that part not a good time with a
mr. Spielberg there were a couple of
ones and people in the last couple of
decades so I know how much they enjoyed
it so I Chris and Bryce are fantastic
and I had my character as something nice
to say about the value of science and
human curiosity investigation in fact
based reality et spoke with Goldblum at
the New York City premiere of his new
animated film Isle of Dogs centered
around a story where all dogs in Japan
are quarantined on a remote island if
you were to be exiled like the dogs in
this film where would you like to be
exiled
my backyard I just stay there with my
two boys and our dog woody and my wife
Emily we would just stay there and
cuddle I'd like to myself under house
arrest yes and play jazz all day
[Music]
[Applause]